hey guys right up hey guys i'm ryan
right today i'm gonna be doing my top 10
most anticipated films of 2015 now i
know i'm gonna piss off some of you i
simply not putting your anticipated film
of the year on the air but it's my
[ __ ] list so [ __ ] off [ __ ] we need
to count down backwards number 10
mission impossible 5 i really dig the
Mission Impossible series I think they
get better every movie starting from
part 3 meaning three and four got better
I just signed stupid right I love
mission impossible 3 and I love ghost
Protocol they're very different but I
love them and what I love about the
franchise is they always bring on a new
director and I have some concerns
because I'm not a big fan of the
director they brought on he's a great
writer but I was a big fan of jack
reacher mcdeere doll so wrote the
tourists and Jack the giant slayer so
I'm not the hugest fan of him but he did
work with him on edge of tomorrow and he
wrote the usual suspects so I'm sure
probably with a good producing
creativity from Tom Cruise I don't know
if JJ Abrams is involved in this one as
well I bet it could be great i saw some
of that footage of tom cruise on the
plane that's all it took to get me
excited and i love Tom Cruise I love me
a Tom Cruise movie love love ma 10
muchas gracias Senor number 9 would have
to be Terminator Genisys ok Terminator 3
I thought was really fun salvation oh
whoa can we just wipe the slate clean
please that was horrible I saw this
trailer and I'll be honest it's getting
mixed feedback I really dug it I think
it looks pretty [ __ ] sweet actually
to see our returning back is when you
know have me the aging Terminator is
interesting to me and I like the Star
Trek reboot kind of thing either doing
with it by mixing up the timelines
Terminator 2 will always be one of my
top five favorite movies of all time
love the [ __ ] out of that movie so I'm
always having like a childhood
when it comes to these Terminator films
being great again i bring james cameron
back man number eight I'm gonna sound
stupid here spectra Specter spectra will
go spectra it's the new james bond film
skyfall [ __ ] fantastic experience and
they're bringing back salmon it's not
usual where they bring back the same
director back to back for a Bond film so
to see them bringing back Sam Mendes and
you know Daniel Craig of course that's
pretty [ __ ] sweet and I think don't
quote me on this but I think Christoph
Waltz is in it now I just have so much
faith in it you know you like that
worries me is like the pressure of them
feeling like they have to top Skyfall if
they just make their own standalone Bond
film again that would be fantastic I
don't think they should get concerned
about that and you know cuz and I hope
audiences don't get concerned about it
the cool thing about Bond films is that
they tend to be different from one
another by bringing on the same director
I'm hope we don't get exactly the same
thing as Skyfall but something fresh
against something different number seven
would have to be Jurassic world I'm
still wondering why the [ __ ] the
dinosaurs still got a theme park after
all the [ __ ] that happened but hey it's
just cool to see them back in this world
again I think it looks like an updated
version of you know what we saw a
Jurassic Park in the 90s it looks
intense it looks scary and you know I
love Chris Pratt and I think it's great
that it's been able to redefine his
image it's just why the [ __ ] would they
open up for everyone did I learned her
why would you create a hybrid dinosaur I
like oh we're gonna make it
unpredictable animal like how it's
stupid but anyway uh besides that though
it's just cool to see it's like I I'm
sure when I watch them live i'm not
gonna give a [ __ ] about any of that i'm
just gonna enjoy the film number six
would have to be chappie neill blomkamp
he did district nine is it Elysium I
love his style I even saw some of his
concept art that he had for an alien
movie which looked pretty sweet like
alien
as in like the Alien franchise you know
Ripley and all that I mean it looks like
wall-e and Robocop I think that's what
he actually said I might just be quoting
him here it looks like wall-e and
Robocop and with that neill blomkamp
touch and i [ __ ] love his direction
you know a lot of people were let down
by Elysium I personally dug it i mean i
felt like it might have you know had to
succumb to some studio stuff other than
that i still thought it was a very
inventive film i think this guy's a
great director and hopefully he does
take on the halo movie one day number
five would have to be Kingsman the
Secret Service my favorite kinds of like
if we're talking about movies that were
going to watch in the theaters like my
top five is what I have there Kingsman
the Secret Service just looks like a
total [ __ ] blast Matthew Vaughn fight
with kick ass and x-men first class and
now he's doing this it he's like the
perfect person to adapt comic books he's
great ma'am and Colin Firth in it is it
like seeing him commit to this the lead
the new guy looks great Samuel Jackson's
having a fun time it looks like a really
fun movie it looks created it looks
badass it looks funny it's like anything
a great movie going experience should be
number four the hateful eight don't know
much about this film I'm avoiding
reading stuff about it because of this
script being leaked but it's Tarantino
like how can you like you hear Tarantino
has a movie in your bound to get excited
you know I'm sure there's gonna be some
comments me Lego is so overrated Django
Unchained and kill bill vol.1 are two of
my favorite movies of all time health to
have this happen i'm so glad he's still
making the film because i know that
after the script leak she was like oh
we're not gonna make this anymore i'm so
happy that he's actually doing the film
now I avoided even hear any casting of
this but I'm definitely gonna be there
number three how can you not mention and
here's why I piss people off because
number three Avengers 2 age of Ultron
here's the thing my marvel excitement
has semi died down I think we just get
so much Marvel now that you kind of
become immune to things and they're not
as exciting as they once were but I have
so much face in fate I have so much face
I have so much faith in Jaws
Weeden and I have so much faith in this
cast cos Avengers one was amazing it was
fantastic I believe that joss whedon is
one of the few directors who can go I
know how I can make this Avenger story
even better so I'm [ __ ] jacked and
the performance I'm really excited for
is James Spader as Ultron you know even
though I know it doesn't look like James
Spader the entire [ __ ] time i'm still
like James Spader's the [ __ ] so yeah
great addition number two would have to
be tomorrow land we were talking my
mission a possible earlier ghost
Protocol amazing the incredibles is
probably my favorite animated movie of
all time to have Brad Bird like if I
hear Brad Bird I'm gonna get excited I'm
gonna want to fly cuz he lumbered I i
love my joke Tomorrowland just the
teaser alone i was like i can i'll buy a
ticket right now based off just that
teaser that doesn't tell you anything
about the movie it looks that [ __ ]
cool visually tonally and just in george
clooney brittany robertson she's or
Robinson I don't remember she's you know
good buzz I call her great something
yeah mmm she's blonde graduations and
number one would have to be star wars
the force awakens like I said this list
is mainly based off of films i must see
in the theaters like a must-see and
hands down not just saying this i'm not
trying to satisfy a fan boys here like i
really like that trailer was like if
there's one movie i have to see opening
night not even the night I I gotta go to
like their midnight show which don't
[ __ ] exist anymore because now
they're like 8pm shows the day before so
it's technically being released the day
before don't know why they [ __ ] do
that now but anyway star wars the force
awakens arguably it's probably the most
anticipated film of the year you know
surpassing Avengers 2 it looks awesome
just that teaser alone as well like same
thing with Tomorrowland that teaser I
don't need to see any more footage I am
so [ __ ] there so yeah those are my
top 10 list thank you guys for watching
if you're new to the real rejects you
can subscribe
because we're you know worth your time
and more ways than a hooker ever is
enjoy yourselves and have a good January